Arena difficult uh game today with the
black pieces against an ALICE Lee that
was very different to the Alice Lee that
we've seen in the first part of uh this
event when she was struggling how did
you approach this game and take us
through the critical
moments yeah well um first of all that's
a really fascinating position that you
guys had on the board with Karana uh
Neeman um looks like Fabby has a nice a
nice game there and um well in terms of
my game my game was actually not hard at
all it was the easiest game I've played
in a very long time in this tournament
um so I didn't have any problems from
the opening um like at all uh opening
prep worked out really well um obviously
you know you would like to play for more
um you know just to keep a glimmer of a
hope alive right but at the same time
okay you're black and I mean she played
well enough not to really give me I
think any chances in this game and
actually I wanted to talk about
something more interesting than this
game which is like uh my amazing friends
you know because it's been a pretty
tough tournament for me okay and um yeah
something a little bit different you
know um yeah it's been a tough
tournament for me especially this series
of draws that I had um just you know one
sort of crushing disappointment after
another actually the third draw with
Jennifer was probably the uh the easiest
to get over because by that point it was
just kind of comical how I was uh
playing um but those first two were
really painful you know and I feel you
know very lucky that I have my group of
friends like people that I do my walks
with here in St Louis people I talk to
on the phone people I talk to by text um
you know you even my kind of my fans and
supporters that write to me on Facebook
I mean just like everyone has been um
you know doing such an amazing job of
supporting me so I wanted to just kind
of talk about that a little bit because
you get to points in you're life you
know you're 39 and I don't I don't
remember having these kinds of
friendships like 10 years ago so it's
like some of these friendships have been
you know being built up over a decade or
more um you know some of them are some
things that I've built you know in the
last year but um you know when you have
friends like that you uh feel very very
rich you know very blessed and so that's
why even though this tournament is not
uh going so well for me you know at
least not not in a terms of fighting for
first place but um yeah but overall I
feel I feel very very happy that is very
uh well put uh Arena thank you very much
for that now you mentioned at the
beginning about this glimmer of hope of
course you talking about getting first
place and it does seem like right now if
one of either Karissa or begim wins
their respective games there's not going
to be any more hope for the first place
what do you make of this historical race
between these two
ladies yeah definitely interesting how
it shaped out because they were both in
amazing form um it's something that you
don't really see so often it kind of uh
hearkens back to those years when Anna
and I were you know trying to get us
close to the perfect scor as we could
and we would have those kinds of scores
of like seven out of eight and it would
be a question of you know who would win
first um and then for you know a long
time I really don't remember a situation
like this where people have you know
seven out of eight two points ahead of
everyone else um so it's definitely a
special tournament like that they're
both in really good form and um yeah I
play beum tomorrow so it's going to be
exciting absolutely big Clash for you
against beim uh tomorrow any special
strategies any special motivations for
this game because we know you are doing
quite well in general against begim
you've eliminated her twice in the
American Cup so this one is definitely
going to be a very interesting
Clash yeah I mean I feel like I'm in a
decent place like look I've had a hard
time here you know I feel like actually
getting over those disappointments that
was really the toughest because you know
you haven't lost a single game in this
tournament but actually you feel like
you've taken a lot of losses with the
way these games have went um obviously I
could have lost a lot of you know I
could have won a lot of games and it
turns many winning games into losing
games so there was a lot going on um
but you know now where I am I mean I
feel like this game it was actually kind
of nice to have a a quieter day like a
day that's not going on for five and a
half hours and there was like really no
stress here um and you know I got two
two more games and I feel like I at
least you know I I kind of survived
psychologically I'm definitely feeling
like you know like those games did not
break me well that's why you're the
champion that you are with these very
experienced mentality we'll see you
tomorrow Arena yeah Christian I'll just
tell you one last thing one of on one of
my walks with my friends um you know one
of the things he said to me was remember
who you are you know and that was I
think after my second draw maybe against
um ashria that really quite disastrous
game where I was trying to defend a game
where I had been up a pawn you know
remember who you are in the sense like
that you're a fighter yeah you know so
that really um put me back on track and
so yeah thank you to my friends
our congratulations to you uh arena for
all your SE successes in these national
championships